nobody wants to have to
ask for charity but this summer more
people
are having to do it this is my house i'm
sharif and this is my house
these are the um pajamas for sharif
that we got for sharif this is the
bathtub
you feel like the world is coming to an
end sometimes that's the way i feel like
what's happening i'm sick and tired of
this when is this going to stop
can this stop but nobody's telling you
anything and you're just dead moaning to
yourself so sometimes just have to
bring the positivity out to make
yourself happy
the positivity is here in human form her
sister
and support bubble nikki
hobbit 19 if we start from now we won't
finish it
it's it's affected a lot of people two
beautiful charities they've been able to
give me
stuff and i've collected it with one did
not even call me she just came to my
door and knocked on the door
and dropped it and there it is plantain
rice and
i said god bless you how did you know i
need that
so it is now ask for the help now don't
wait for tomorrow
you have to ask then you will be given
all the data shows quite clearly that
those who can least afford it
are the ones being hit hardest by covet
19
both the virus itself and the fallout
from it
before the pandemic it was estimated
that there were 76
000 children in manchester in poverty
that's enough to fill old trafford
football stadium and everyone that we've
spoken to agrees
that figure is rising
almost three-quarters of a million
people in the uk have lost their jobs
since
march when lockdown began i delivered to
somebody
recently and she was in tears as she
accepted what i dropped off for
and she was quite overcome we're in
harper hay in east manchester
sam and anthony are the next grateful
parents
and some bedding what have you noticed
particularly during lockdown that's
been harder after the kids well i'm
spending more money on the kids
yeah yeah so how many have you got five
one on the work
really how far is this one uh well
what's been the stuff that you've needed
things for the baby mainly yeah
that was it and then she just asked if
we wanted clothes for the other kids and
stuff
so i was working before all this well
yeah
anthony did five years here he was an
agency worker
who was cast adrift as businesses
everywhere look to simply survive
sometimes you feel proper depression i
mean like because the kids would
and the family didn't rely on you you
know i mean when you're bringing in a
bit of money
but then when that's gone it's like
that's true i [ __ ] won't get out of
the job till i'll be out today because i
was used to being like you know every
single day
and like after a bit it's all right you
know they break but then like
it comes back when you get bored and
stressed and stuff like thinking about
money and everything else where your
next bit of money is going to come from
next stop a community centre in newton
heath to pick up a donation
the pandemic has really crucified us
frustration i think is a big word in new
york at the moment
people are frustrated with everything
it's not a healthy position to believe
it's not healthy
no no definitely not healthy um
and i say your stress levels go up don't
they up through the roof
your mental health then suffers and then
not that you will take it out on the kid
but you could yeah
but there's a lot of children being
shouted at
the donations arrive back at wood street
in the middle of manchester
where they've been doing this for the
past 150 years
and this is what poverty looked like in
1900 at this charity
the boys who if they survived to
adulthood would have been sent to the
front line
in world war one
so this basement would have had two or
three hundred people a night sleeping on
the floors
it was a different era and some people
struggle to accept that poverty exists
today in modern britain
but here the evidence comes through the
doors
every single day here we are 2020
and the work that wood street does
really hasn't changed
and i think that's quite sad really when
you look at that you know that was such
a modern country
but no government has ever tackled
the issue of child poverty in this
country properly
generations of the same families here
have needed the same help
that their parents did gold doesn't want
that
he's 15. you'll remember his mum's
birthday
earlier eventually like this corona
house will just
wipe away hopefully and everything can
go back to normal
you had enough of it yeah
everyone has had enough of this virus
new bedding from the charity
it's just a short-term fix there are
families across this country
that need help